I forgot to add Purity except Ethan
Klein Ethan Klein likes his wife to have
multiple men that is what that is is
that what your ideal is well that's what
Ethan's no no you want no anyways what
up guys welcome to the just early things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
Whiteboard video before I start don't
forget to subscribe
you can build a way you're gonna be
notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams So today we're
going to be talking about how women the
Modern Woman has lost all the things
that men value basically useless when it
comes to reproduction and from a
historically historical perspective now
this isn't insulting anybody personally
but as a group let's just look what the
numbers say so the issue we have what do
men value when we go back to Evolution
right we want to pass on our genes
whatever men value symmetry so also I'm
a bad speller so if I spell anything
wrong you know AKA Beauty I guess we'll
say in shape and let's just say you know
motherly qualities you know and I'm not
I'm not going to get two in the in the
weeds here but let's just say mother
quality so you know good with kids
um Cooks cleans and even even if you
Outsource that stuff they still want you
know them to be feminine whatever now
let's talk about the average American
woman oh hold on I dropped I
dropped it
now let's let's talk about the average
American woman now I know there's
unicorns I know there's women that
aren't like that but all I'm talking
about is just the group so here we have
the average American woman so she's
about five five five six
um she's 170 pounds
um by the time she gets married
um the average age of first marriage is
getting close to 30. um it's 31 in the
UK so I'm just going to use 31. um so
five six 170 pounds the average wife
let's say that's probably a better way
to put it 31 years old has slept with um
between five to eight men I mean is a
very disputed number you know I've also
seen studies that say 15 I've also seen
studies that say 20 but let's be
conservative today five to eight okay so
she's five six 170 pounds 31 years old a
five to eight men and we'll give the men
one
1.2 kids on top of that there is a 90
chance a 90 chance he's on birth control
or has been on birth control at some
point in her life one out of three
chance she's had an one out of three
chance she has an STD
um and the average woman is not a good
cook not a good Clique not a good not
good at cleaning and honestly hasn't
spent a lot of time around around
children you know so this is again the
average American woman okay let's let's
give her hair what did men want again
from a historical point of view and an
evolutionary point of view they want
Beauty in shape so the average woman yes
the average woman is 170 pounds dang it
not in shape okay the average woman I
forgot to add Purity except Ethan Klein
Ethan Klein likes his wife to have
multiple men that is what that is is
that what your idea that's what Ethan's
no no you want no anyway so let's let's
from a historical point of view men also
wanted Purity because they wanted to
ensure paternity now that we've made
Modern ways around this
but this does not change the fact that
this is what men want so can we say the
average tick is pure
when she slept with five plus men a
hundred years ago 85 percent of women
were virgins 85 now most women have
slept with over five men now men also
want a legacy right do they get that
with 1.2 children I mean maybe and
Purity so if one out of three women has
had
ninety percent have been on birth
control one out of three has an STD are
are is the the average woman pure
nowadays now a lot of times I get
flacked because I will not acknowledge
that all women were like are not now a
lot of times I get Flack oh oh a lot of
times I get Flack because I don't
acknowledge that not all women are like
that so I'd like to say now not every
woman is like this okay however from a
historical point of view 95 of women are
because only five percent of women are
virgins on their wedding day so we get a
lot of women that come forward and say
I'm a traditional woman but they're
really not a traditional woman because
again they've had multiple partners they
didn't get married young and this isn't
to insult anybody none of this means
they're bad people it just means that in
general the average American woman has
lost the things that men value
um now let's talk about the institution
of marriage now a lot of men will still
men adapt let's be honest guys sex is a
need for men it's not a want so a lot of
times when we shame men for saying well
why would you date those women or you
guys accept it and we understand that
but if a guy wants to reproduce he kind
of has to deal with what the market
gives him and that puts it on the women
like what are we giving the men so let's
talk about marriage a lot of men I mean
do you expect your future wife to be a
virgin no no none of the guys expect
this anymore they know this is what
we're dealing with this is the modern
market so let's talk about marriage the
issue with marriage is now we have a
roughly 50 divorce rate so 50 of of
marriages are getting divorced or
marriages are winding up in divorce and
men only get their kids 10 to 20 percent
of the time so if you care about Legacy
and you care about your children which I
would imagine if you married him he does
he does even if it doesn't work out he
now loses his children she now has the
opportunity to take half of his stuff so
can we really blame men for thinking
that's not a good deal that's not a good
deal and it also kind of makes it a bit
disingenuous when the you always see the
Trad con saying or the Christians saying
which I do love you guys I am I am
Catholic and conservative but but it
makes it a bit disingenuous when they'll
say oh well why don't you just find a
good woman you're the problem because
you can't get a good woman well 95
percent of women aren't virgins on their
wedding day when a hundred years ago
that was a prerequisite for marriage we
can't really put it on the men it's
really on the women to improve these
numbers here
um so again we go we have the marriage
institution which is very much
discriminates against men it's a 50
failure rate and most people wouldn't go
into a business contract with a fifty
percent failure rate where you know that
if they leave they get your most
valuable asset which I would argue is
your children I would argue there's
nothing more important and valuable than
children and now what does this lead to
single mother homes now we all know that
when now now where the couples broken up
right you know this is the couple they
broke up okay we all know that when moms
raise children the kids are more likely
I'm not going to draw it but they're
more likely to drop out of school
they're they're more likely to run away
from home they're more likely to end up
in a mental institution they make up 80
percent of prisoners most of the
homeless are from single mother home so
now men think huh I could get married
and there's a 50 chance she'll take half
and I'm only going to see my kid there's
an 80 chance if we do divorce she gets
primary custody meaning that my kid
won't even get to carry out my legacy
because all of these risk factors
influence my child a lot of I'll hear a
lot of Trad cons which I do love you
guys but I'll hear a lot of Trad cons
talk about how well the men just need to
be better but you know in my opinion
humbly I would say
it starts with the women before we talk
about the men because even if the men
improve there's a 95 chance he ain't
gonna get a virgin which historically
that was a prerequisite for marriage so
um yeah this is why we have lost
everything that men value and this is
why the average American chick is you
know no longer dateable but the good
news is a lot of these things can be
improved
um the weight thing is a start you know
getting married before you have children
is a start so you know let me know what
you guys think in the comment like the
video on your way out or maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'm crazy maybe the quality of
women is just amazing and I am just a
Debbie Downer I don't know like the
video guys subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time